the MPD numbers are out and it looks
like PlayStation and call of duty are
sitting at the top of the charts for
both the month of december and 2015
ahead of the monthly report sony
released a statement thanking their fans
and partners for the impressive year as
we reflect on an amazing year we want to
thank fans and partners for making
PlayStation 4 the top selling console in
December and in 2015 ps4 also had the
strongest third-party software sales in
2015 in the US according to NPD the
playstation 4 sold 5.7 million units
over the holiday season and has sold
well over 35 million worldwide since it
launched in 2013 meanwhile call of duty
black ops 3 was the top-selling game of
2015 in the US and worldwide according
to Activision and the franchise has sold
over 250 million units in total other
games in the top five were madden NFL 16
fallout 4 star wars battlefront and
grand theft auto 5 oddly enough black
ops 3 and star wars battlefront sold
better on the Xbox one for a more
in-depth list of the top selling
physical games check out the article on
gamespot com